this sign is in a lot of bathrooms right
now and I'm wondering how you feel about
it this is how this is how your network
through TV this is how your station is
promoting your show you look like an
absolute perv in in someone's bathroom
first of all as you know a beginning
stand-up comic I spent so much time in
crappy bar bathrooms yeah I'm so happy
to be now featured out like frame dyeing
a picture on the wall in one yeah but uh
this is this is actually the first time
that we let the marketing department of
true do their own research normally we
say only two facts from the show please
this time they said we research that we
found this really good one about urine
and I really love that we're making
truTV's marketing department doing do
this disgusting research that brings me
a lot of pleasure that now it's not just
our team it's like the poor copywriters
in the marketing department having to
look this crap up well you're doing an
effective job you seem like you'd be the
most depressing person at any party oh
because people would show up in like hey
look I got TOMS shoes not helping anyone
that's where they're so well I just had
a nice shower waste of time
oh well actually what I do yeah exactly
what I do here buzzkill yes
[Applause]
you